trop d'états centralisée s'était
finalement l'un des thèmes de notre
premier débat autour de la santé ensuite
quand on parle des pneus neige ça peut
faire rigoler on se dit c'est un détail
mais qu'est ce qu'on voit au loin un peu
mal fagotée à paris et puis l'a
finalement le secteur libéral une grande
marque qui prend en main sa propre
formation tout ça ça nous amène au au
thème de notre débat nos nouveaux
modèles français bonsoir david djaïz
bonsoir thomas les revenus c'est le
titre de votre livre publié chez les
éditions vous êtes normalien énarque
pour fassiez ans pourrait laisser votre
lit qui nous a donné envie d'organiser
ce débat peut-être aussi pour contrer le
déclinisme ambiant et se dire que ce
n'est pas une fatalité ce ce déclin
français jacques ier également aurore
laluque bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
économiste députée européenne ou siéger
au sein du groupe de l'alliance
progressiste des socialistes et
démocrates vous publiez reconquête au
nom de l'intérêt général c'est aux
éditions les petits matins erwan le nord
bonjour bonjour bonsoir du vous êtes
partenaires au sein du cabinet de
conseil alterman membre du conseil
scientifique et d'évaluation de la
fondation pour l'innovation politique et
vous portez vos idées libérales dans des
chroniques notamment dans les médias
l'opinion ou encore les exactement et
matthieu croissandeau évidemment qui
restait à mes côtés david jay je
commence évidemment avec vous puisque
c'est votre livre qui nous a inspirés
bon vous dit on va peut-être partir de
concerts vite on a plus de modèles
collectif depuis quand moi je pense
depuis le milieu des années 70 mais pour
comprendre ça faut revenir à l'après
guerre en 1945 la france qui se découvre
dans la glace c'est une société qui est
ruinée sur le plan économique il ya deux
millions de prisonniers déportés un
quart des infrastructures sont détruites
c'est bien plus considérables qu après
la première guerre mondiale et surtout
c'est une société qui est ruinée sur le
plan psychologique l'effondrement
militaire de 1940 il faut imaginer ce
que c'est dans un pays qui se vivait
comme la première armée du monde tout le
monde connaît l'étrange défaite de marc
bloch pourtant pas beaucoup reparlé
d'ailleurs au moment de la crise que
vides et il va se passer entre 44 et 47
malgré la conflictuelle it et politiques
et sociales qui est inévitable en
démocratie un processus très intéressant
de construction d'un nouveau modèle
autour de quelques principes d'abord la
confiance dans l'avenir c'est pas rien
ça la confiance dans l'avenir surtout
aujourd'hui nos enfants on a
l'impression qu'ils vivront moins bien
que nous qu'ils vont vivre la
catastrophe écologique là on est
confiant dans le fait qu'ils vivront
mieux deuxièmement un développement
industriel sans précédent tirée par
l'état tgv concorde ariane programme
nucléaire il ya quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire au niveau technologique
qui se joue à ce moment là et puis
évidemment la sécurité sociale les
ordonnances de 44 c'est une révolution
aujourd'hui c'est comme l'air qu'on
respire quand on prend à tesco vide il
est remboursé par la solidarité
nationale
plus pour longtemps plus pour longtemps
parce qu'heureusement l'épidémie décroît
mais ça fait partie presque de notre
environnement naturel
donc il se passe quelque chose un modèle
intégrateur et jetée puis au milieu des
années 70 la mondialisation arrivant les
grands chocs énergétique mondiale
pétrolière allait sur l'it rollier
arrivant ce modèle va être très
sévèrement ébranlé en quelques sortes et
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'on vit depuis
40 ans sur une décomposition de ce
modèle d'après guerre et c'est ce qui
explique une partie de notre malheur
parce qu'on a une classe politique soit
qui et c'est bien légitime et c'est
défendre certains acquis du modèle
d'après hier soi et dans l'invocation du
modèle allemand du modèle suédois alors
maintenant ce qui a le vent en poupe
c'est les modèles asiatiques la corée du
sud taïwan etc mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on repart pas des forces et des
faiblesses de la société de l'économie
française on parlait du luxe et de
l'artisanat tout à l'heure repartons des
forces et des faiblesses et construisant
ce modèle qui nous permettra de faire
face aux défis du 21e siècle à commencer
par la catastrophe écologique et on va
justement parlé de ce modèle que vous
avez en tête peut être une réaction
générale sur sur cet impératif à
inventer un nouveau modèle français à
nouveau modèle de société qu'est ce que
vous en pensez ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec eux déjà le principe effectivement
dans le civil ça commence par la
nécessité de dire créons notre propre
modèle plus d'eau à chaque fois de se
référer souvent l'allemagne le japon la
suède à témoin de quelque chose est la
mode mais faut revenir effectivement à
la base qui est 45 45 on a quoi on a une
vision très claire et on a une volonté
qui est celle de la prospérité pourquoi
parce qu'on a un peuple qui épuisé par
la guerre effectivement d'un pays qui
est en ruine et la classe politique
effectivement va trouver un compromis
les gaullistes aussi bien que mon grand
père dix ans communiste par exemple
n'avaient pas la même vision des choses
ils trouvent un compromis pour se faire
du bien en fait parce qu'on sort d'une
période absolument dramatique et le
compromis se fait aussi autour de la
prospérité il ya l'idée que ça va être
dur et c'est ça autour de la
planification d'ailleurs ça va être dur
il va falloir mettre toutes les forces
de vives de la nation autour de la table
ça va être dur mais derrière ça y est
quand même cette idée de prospérité là
le sujet que nous avons aujourd'hui
c'est que
je ne sais pas si nous avons une vision
moi je pense qu'en fait il y en a une
mais qu'elle n'est pas forcément assumer
c'est à dire que le tournant auquel
david fait référence qu'il tournant des
années 70 80 c'est quoi c'est la contre
révolution néolibérale en gros pincer on
sort du keynésianisme et au lieu
malheureusement d'embrasser l'écologie
politique on va aller vers une forme de
néo libérale c'est à dire qu'on prend
l'état mais on le met au service non
plus de l'intérêt général mais quand
même des plus puissants à mon sens et on
n'a pas de libéro finalement en a des
néolibéraux et on a une vision qui peut
assumer dans certains pays mais qui en
france par exemple je trouve n'est pas
vraiment assumé par notre classe
politique ce qui fait on a un modèle
quelque part français je pense mais qui
est peut-être pas celui que david et moi
par exemple nous aimerions voir émerger
il ya un modèle qui ne dit pas son nom
qui fait que petit à petit on a eu ce
que galbraith s'appelle une sorte d'état
prédateurs wang noi que le nom rend
qu'est-ce que vous est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut forcément inventer un
nouveau modèle tient déjà ses l'accord
son constat qui a pas de film on a
besoin on manque d'une vision collective
en france et jeu mais je pense aussi que
c'est pas propre à la france là elle
succède et populisme convoi l'ensemble
de pays occidentaux montrent que c'est
une crise qui est une crise de la
démocratie occidentale il ya
probablement des éléments français mais
ce que je de plus large
donc ça je suis tout à fait d'accord sur
ce constat sur les éléments de
deux historiques côté l'après-guerre je
suis assez d'accord évidemment je vais
avoir une divergence c'est sur les
raisons qui ont conduit à cette à cette
crise aujourd'hui c'est à dire que moi
je crois que effectivement eu un choc et
le choc de la mondialisation il ya un
hoax un autre choc plus tard qui a été
celui de la numérisation du monde dans
les années 90 qui a eu un choc européen
de réunification qui a et 2 qui a changé
beaucoup de
d'éléments économique en europe le ce et
qui ce sont des chocs qui au fond sont
portés par la même tendance copine que
que 1945 sont portés par la même
tendance forte qu'on trouve dans
l'ensemble de la de la révolution
industrielle depuis depuis ses débuts
c'est à dire la recherche de croissance
l'innovation et qui a péché qui a peiné
à accompagner cette transformation c'est
l'état dès lors que moi je crois que
aujourd'hui notre problème ne vient pas
de la mondialisation néolibérale ou des
transformations néolibérale ce que je
parle bien convaincus qu'elle est
gouvernée la france elle vient de
l'incapacité du modèle français délire
de l'état français et de ceux du modèle
social français à c'est à avoir
accompagné ces transformations depuis 30
40 ans on a un état qui est resté dans
logique de dépenser toujours plus de
s'étendre sans repenser fondamentalement
le rôle de son action et le malaise il
vient de là c'est à dire qu'on a
effectivement des chocs des chocs qui
créent des victimes mais plus les
systèmes d'accompagnement qui pouvaient
exister avant et à trop trop centralisée
trop burin cube bureaucratisé c'est
quand même un des constats que vous
faites aussi dans votre livre je pense
que les torts sont partagés c'est à dire
qu'entre le l'économie libérale et la
sueur étatisation après 45 y avait quand
même alors je dis et 10 pas du tout
certain de préciser puisque parfois on
me reproche on me dit non non il y avait
du conflit 47 ça a été difficile les
communistes quitte le gouvernement et
ses drames et ce qui est intéressant
c'est de passer un peu derrière le récit
gaullien d'une instabilité chronique de
la quatrième république pour montrer
qu'en fait il s'est passé des choses
très intéressantes et que 1958 n'est
peut-être pas autant une rupture qu'on
le dit et je reviens à votre question je
crois que les torts sont partagés il y
avait après 45 une sorte de pacte entre
l'état la société et l'entreprise et à
partir des années 70 qu'on voit c'est
des chemins qui divergent c'est à dire
effectivement on a des entreprises qui
s'internationalise y compris dans la
détention du capital qui sont détenus
beaucoup par des fonds anglo-saxons etc
les fonds anglo saxon il s'en fiche un
peu de l'implantation territoriale des
retombées sociales de la présence d'une
usine ils sont plutôt sur des tableaux
excel et des arbitrages et l'état c'est
vrai que l'état c'est quand même alourdi
il s'est bureaucratisé il à la dépense
sociale n'a cessé de progresser avec une
efficacité parfois décevante par rapport
à moi je suis très attaché au modèle
social français mais il faut reconnaître
que efficacité été assez décevante et
puis la société base la crise
démocratique elle n'a échappé à personne
quand on voit les taux de participation
aux élections est une véritable
sécession démocratique et donc moi mon
livre c'est vraiment un plaidoyer un peu
j'allais dire d'intérêt général pour
dire et si on veut nous mettre entre
gens de bonne volonté autour de la table
pour reconstruire une sorte de air act
qu'est l'état et sa société entreprise
moi je chante votre démarche il faut la
saluer parce que déjà il c'est une
démarche systémique et vous êtes peu
d'intellectuels aujourd'hui à proposer
de nouveaux modèles repensée du sol au
plafond donc ça c'est assez fort après
j'ai une interrogation c est ce qu un
nouveau modèle est pas le produit de
l'histoire plutôt que le produit d'un
manifeste et là on a bien dit qu'il ya
eu des circonstances exceptionnelles en
45 qui ont fait que par un accord à la
fois cimenté dans le haut par le conseil
national de la résistance et ensuite on
va dire un esprit de bonne volonté ou de
sursaut ou de résilience ou de volonté
de survivre communiste gaulliste se sont
mis d'accord pour pour poser les
fondements de cette nouvelle société
française aujourd'hui on peut
s'interroger les circonstances
historiques et sont est là mais on n'a
pas ce sursaut exceptionnel pourquoi
est-ce que c'est pas aussi ne une crise
de du dialogue de la décision il ya des
pays qui ont été confrontés vous en avez
cité quelques-uns à des à des moments de
rupture que ce soit les pays bas avec
les accords de wassenaar compétiteurs
compétitivité contre voilà forme de
nouveau contrat social elle avait à
l'époque il ya la moitié de la
population qui travaille l'autre ne
travaille pas aux pays-bas des dépenses
publiques qui sont à 60% donc c'est
c'est monstrueux et syndicats patronat
se mettre d'accord parce qu'une forme de
consensus sur ça ne peut plus durer on
prend l'exemple allemand déferré formes
artistiques issues d'une certaine façon
et est très décrié après mais sont aussi
le produit de cette culture du dialogue
donc est-ce que sans cette culture du
dialogue c'est possible ps qu' un
manifeste peut se retrouver comme ça à
appliquer moi j'ai aucune prétention à
ce que nous manifestent va appliquer de
cul mais aussi une contribution alors je
dis à la fois c'est une pièce du puzzle
et j'espère que tout le monde les
citoyens ont participé en candidat sans
non pas vous serez ravis que mille
fleurs s'épanouissent
je me faisais le chinois mais
plaisanterie a pas ce que je veux dire
c'est que vous avez raison sur les chocs
historique cercle quand on regarde les
150 ans d'histoire la république
française et de moments de consolidation
du modèle républicain c'est après 1870
la guerre franco prussienne désastre
pour le second empire et là on va avoir
à la fois les grandes lois de liberté la
liberté de la presse qui nous permet de
nous parler aujourd'hui et l'instruction
dans les campagnes c'est formidable les
années 1880 la république des jules
1945 on vient d'en parler donc c'est
vrai que c'est souvent après des chocs
traumatiques moi je crois qu'on peut
s'épargner la nécessité d'une guerre ou
d'un choc traumatique à condition
effectivement de construire ce consensus
et dit on vient d'en vivre un
particulier je viens de vivre c'est
peut-être et on est à l'heure des chocs
planétaire c'est à dire que au fond qu
vide comme la can le mur climatique cd
choc planétaire mais je suis persuadé
qu' on ne construira pas seulement des
réponses planétaire à des chocs
planétaire et contre associe contrats
sociaux ça existe il faut que les
sociétés soient capables de répondre à
ces chocs d'absorber ces chocs et
aujourd'hui on vit quand même une
catastrophe climatique la france c'est
ce que j'explique avec mon concept
d'économie du bien-être elle a en
réalité les talents les infrastructures
les savoir faire pour construire des
secteurs enfin pour développer des
secteurs économiques qui permettront en
quelque sorte d'être à la fois
performants économiquement performant
socialement et sobre sur le plan
énergétique
c'est l'économie du bien-être c'est pas
le caire on parle souvent c'est pas le
cas
l'agriculture de la transition agricole
la santé l'éducation l'urbanisme durable
la silver economy qui va créer quand
même dans les poches des dents pour les
seniors ou les personnes très âgées
c'est 40% des postes de soignants ou des
dents qu'on va créer dans les prochaines
années donc ces cds c'est clair qu'ils
sont absolument majeur qui sont
créateurs de richesses et en tant qu ils
sont sobres sur le plan écologique et
moi je sens que c'est plus intéressant
d'avoir un débat sur cette prospérité là
plutôt que de dire la décroissance la
décroissance on a eu un débat sur la
décroissance la semaine dernière qu'ils
étaient passionnants comme elle à lui qu
est-ce que finalement c'est le bon
moment est-ce qu'il faut réinventer la
une société post covin c'est le bon
moment malheureusement je pense que la
loupe et un petit peu importe pour
entonner les moment de bascule sont
toujours les moments de crise toujours
les moment justement où on peut remettre
des choses sur la table parce que la
puissance publique aussi en rapport de
force là malheureusement ça n'a pas
totalement été fait et côté côté
français après ça n'a pas été fait selon
les critères que je défends moi parce
que ça ne vous a pas échappé je ne suis
pas au gouvernement ma famille politique
c'est avec cette manne d'argent qu'il
fallait réorienter l'économie vers les
services publics vers l'investissement
vers l'investissement notamment dans la
transition écologique pourquoi ça nous
permettait de relancer de réorienter
l'économie comme ce que byden essaye de
faire coter côté américain et de mettre
notre société sur la voix justement du
durable et du long terme de relier en
fait qu'on a fait en 45 le court terme
le moyen terme et long termes là c'était
possible et ça c'est malheureusement ça
a été un loupé l'etranger sens du plan
de relance qui est fléché il était
strictement rien compte tenu de
l'urgence ensuite on a un gros problème
dans tous les pays européens ces packs
français de de manque d'investissement
il nous faut de l'investissement public
il nous faut l'investissement privé et
ça ça permet de relancer correctement
l'économie est en plus de manière
intelligente dix ans c'est d'ailleurs
vers des choses en a cruellement besoin
donc ça ça a été un grand louper
malheureusement je crains que il voit là
il va falloir attendre pas mal d'années
on a conscience
résidentiel elle peut aussi je l'espère
malheureusement pour l'instant on est
plutôt plus tôt émietté j'espère qu'à
moindre un sens des responsabilités qui
fera qu'on réussira peut-être d'avoir ce
choc justement qui permet de nous unir
mais apparemment pour l'instant c'est
pas c'est pas la tendance battu il ya
des candidats qui propose des nouveaux
modèles ça c est pas tous déjà mais y'en
à alençon surprise on trouve ceux qui
proposent un nouveau modèle se trouve
plutôt du côté de la radicalité sert
ceux qui veulent renverser la table
comme les candidats d'extrême gauche par
exemple philippe poutou pour le npa ou
nathalie arthaud pour lutte ouvrière
après c'est difficile de parler de
nouveau modèle quand on sait plus ce
sont les lointains vérité de la
quatrième internationale
ça commence à dater mais enfin comme
leur modèle n'a jamais été appliquée
pourquoi pas on peut au moins les
qualifier de nouveaux modèles jean luc
mélenchon lui aussi une vision assez
systémique qu'il faut lui reconnaître ça
il propose un nouveau modèle assez
complet puisqu'il passe à la fois par
une approche institutionnelle une
approche géopolitique j'allais dire
l'approché écologique il approche
économique social peut être même
culturelle et puis dans une moindre
mesure les partisans d'une écologie
radicale type de décroissance sont bien
aussi ou obligés de proposer un nouveau
un nouveau modèle le problème c'est
électoralement et à part quelques
exceptions près ça paye pas forcément
les nouveaux modèles en souvienne une
exception c'est le new deal de roosevelt
mais en france les changements de
paradigmes ne se décrète pas toujours
dans les urnes et ça marche pas toujours
qu'on pourra mais à mon avis pour deux
raisons la première c'est de là que ça
fait peur le vide fait peur et donc il
faut que les circonstances on en parlait
tout à l'heure historique soit
suffisamment exceptionnel pour qu'on ne
regrette rien du monde ancien et sont
soit prêt à se jeter dans le nouveau la
seconde c'est que pour le coup c'est lié
au fait que les français ne croient plus
beaucoup font leur a beaucoup promis des
choses qui pouvait ressembler de près ou
de loin des nouveaux modèles et qui se
sont cassé la figure quelques mois ou
quelques années après près d mitterrand
en 81 qui voulait changer la vie bah il
a été rattrapé par la rigueur jacques
chirac à sa façon qui voulaient réduire
la fracture sociale et qui est une
approche un peu plus inclusive il s'est
fait rattraper aussi par la patrouille
quant à sarkozy nicolas sarkozy aux
manuels macro aussi promettait un
nouveau modèle le premier a été congédié
ou d'inde amanda et le second n'est pas
encore élu juste une chose il ya des
candidats donc qui promettent un beau
modèle et puis il ya ceux qui ne
proposent pas un mois mes yeux ce que ce
que je trouve assez saisissant c'est con
on observe quand même sur cette vague
les déclinistes ou nostalgique beaucoup
font le diagnostic que notre modèle est
à bout de souffle mais il considère que
c'est au bout au bout du compte c'est
parce qu'il a été trahi et donc il
faudrait revenir à son esprit originel
de ces candidats voient la bienvenue
dans l'ère du rheu vous payez pas mal de
gens là dedans record renouer avec la
promesse républicaine ce quelque chose
que vous pouvez trouver chez marine le
pen autour de la liberté après on en
juge on en pense qu'on en veut en tout
cas et et prend la liberté vous pouvez
retrouver sa halal ou l'autre bout de
l'échiquier chez anne hidalgo qui elle
préfère l'égalité elle le bel en parle
dans un renault avec la promesse
républicaine de façon à remettre plus de
justice plus d'égalité mais re vous
trouvez aussi d'en restaurer l'autorité
de l'état ça c'est xavier bertrand ou
restaurer leur travail vous le trouvez
aussi dans la remonte à d'arnaud
montebourg tout ça sent un peu le retour
vers le futur en tout cas un petit goût
de revenez-y on retourne arriérés pas
vraiment de nouveaux modèles
oui parce que en fait les exemples qui
ont été citées par matthieu croissandeau
pour moi c'est pas des modèles c'est des
programmes dans le meilleur des cas et
probablement des slogans dans la dans
l'idée d'un modèle de société en tant
quel tel que je l'entends et dans le
compromis la france est soumise au
dedans ouais je le mets aussi là dedans
mais il ya vraiment l'idée d'un
compromis en fait entre les forces
sociales et productives du pays où par
exemple l'allemagne a là un modèle qui
n'est pas le cas pas transposable tel
quel en france mais qui s'appelle
l'économie sociale de marché de
s'élaborer au monde la réforme monétaire
de 1948 de la loi fondamentale de 1949
et ce qui est extraordinairement
intéressant dans l'histoire de
l'allemagne c'est que à chaque fois
qu'il ya une élection législative
les candidats à la chancellerie font
allégeance à l'économie sociale de
marché qui soit d'ailleurs écolo
spd enfin sociaux démocrates ou chrétien
démocrate c'est très intéressant de voir
c'est est ce que freud heures par
exemple a dit il n'est pas question de
toucher à ce principe intangible de
l'économie sociale de marché donc cette
stabilité monétaire décentralisation
droits fondamentaux il ya des choses qui
sont intéressantes aussi du point de vue
de la discussion d'entreprise face est
un modèle c'est un compromis entre unsa
un projet social etc on pourrait parler
du modèle danois aussi qui est
intéressant mais ce n'est pas
transposable en l'état en france parce
que le danemark si une société de cinq
millions d'habitants le revenu l'écart
de revenus ces deux ans à 3 à peu près
dans la société 80 ou 90 % des salaires
des salariés sont syndiqués donc on peut
pas transposer ça enfants et moi ce que
je dis dans le livre c'est que il ya un
truc qui est fondamentale en france
depuis des siècles c'est l'état est
effectivement cet état moi je fais le
constat qui s'est bureaucratisé qui
s'est alourdie qu'il a un peu dévié de
ce rôle d'aiguillon qu'il a eu pendant
plusieurs siècles il faut retrouver ce
rôle et moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui
l'état il doit plus être simplement dans
la verticalité surplombant dans
l'étouffement en quelque sorte de la
société mais il doit être la vigie il se
passe des choses extraordinaires dans
notre société dans notre économie à des
villes il ya des entreprises et des
associations qui sont dans l'innovation
trouver ce qui marche le partage et le
serre-tête 200 exemple à loos en gohelle
on est passé du noir au vert on a fermé
les puits de mine on a reconstruit une
nouvelle économie à kingersheim on a
inventé de la démocratie participative
dans la bio valley dans la drôme il se
passe des choses extraordinaires il ya
des succès industriel à vire dans le
calvados par exemple ou à figeac dans le
lot l'état son rôle ça doit être quoi
c'est d'aller voir ce qui se fait de
mieux et de donner aux autres les moyens
de développer ces innovations quand il
les a leurré spontanément erwan le nom
est ce que cet état-là n'y trouve grâce
à vos yeux en partie c'est à dire
qu'effectivement j'ai beau être un
libéral convaincu je crois pas que la
france puisse se transformer en
en corée du sud 11 et en amérique du sud
amérique ou même en grande bretagne il
ya une histoire particulière et l'état
français l'êta en france a un rôle très
particulier
cela étant je crois assez peu je crois
effectivement que l'état pardon un rôle
à jouer à jouer pour faciliter les les
transitions pour faciliter les
initiatives mais je crois assez peu pour
le coup à ce que je ressens un peu dans
votre livre qui est cette idée d'état
nouvelle forme d' état stratège ne
croient pas à la capacité de l'état à
identifier des projets et à les
généraliser comme vous le dites parce
que historiquement ça a échoué donc je
crois que le rôle de l'état en france il
a un rôle d'accompagnement il un rôle
important dans l'unité nationale et ça a
été son historiquement sont sam une de
ses missions il a après un rôle pour
favoriser l'innovation et aujourd'hui et
je crois pas qu'il favorise beaucoup
l'innovation on a une fiscalité qui est
lourde une
administration qui est très lourde il
lui reste on a des universités qu'on
voudrait former on a une école qui est
absolument injuste et là à mon avis
l'état un jouet a un rôle à jouer les
rôles fondé les fonctions de l'état
elles sont là et pour inventer ce
nouveau modèle ça doit être un modèle
fait d'opportunités ouverte à tous et ça
passe d'abord par l'éducation mais dans
dans dans ce long tandis que je crois
qu'il ya deux questions il ya quel
nouveau modèle et ça effectivement je
restais d'accord qui a pas beaucoup de
gens qui on propose aujourd'hui et après
la question de la transition vers ce
modèle est là où je rejoins ce que vous
disiez c'est que on on a heureusement
pas de guerre on a heureusement pas de
chocs importants et on entretient quand
même dans une partie du discours
politique cette illusion que le
politique peut tout changer et donc on a
eu ce discours sur des vous l'avez des
différents candidats on a eu le discours
sur le monde d'après après le coït ça se
passe pas comme ça la vraie vie donc le
modèle nouveau modèle français croyants
dans un monde d'après je crois pas
absolument pas un monde d'après
d'ailleurs il est où le monde d'après là
ça fait 1 an ou 2 qui devrait être en
place il est pas la relation est nulle
part parce que le politique peut-être
pas tout changer mais il peut tout
laisser faire et l'asie où je vous
rejoins c'est qu'il ya une forme de
modèles tessit l'été qui a été un modèle
qui s'est fait autour de 2 des 5 lui que
ce soit les inclus dans le monde du
travail au détriment de ceux qui n'en
étaient pas des inclus dans la société
au détriment de ceux qui subissaient des
discriminations enfin tout ce modèle là
il a quand même été en tout cas ni non
pas bénigne mais en tout cas accepté de
façon tacite par la plupart des
formations politiques par la plupart des
grands acteurs socio-économiques que ce
soit syndicats pour le monde du travail
ou associations
si je peux emmener sur ce qui a été dit
la définition d'un modèle aussi ça passe
par le fait de gagner la bataille
culturelle
moi quand je souris quand j'entends
certaines choses parce que c'est s'aider
exemple par exemple qu'on peut utiliser
depuis 10 20 ans avec certains
économistes
quand j'entends le débat sur la
décroissance dont je me résous lui même
si je ne suis pas décroissante isni
croissante croissance vers d'ailleurs je
me réjouis aussi de voir que ya un débat
qui commence quand j'entends parler de
la transition écologique et sociale je
me réjouis aussi mais ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que on est très nombreux dans le
champ universitaire ou death in tech a
parlé de la renaissance air redéfinition
la prospérité et de parler de la
nécessité d'un green new deal de parler
de la semaine vous forcez au niveau
européen notamment
de parler de la planification écologique
la planification écologique c'est alain
lipietz il ya combien il ya 25 ans ou
même plus et donc on voit aussi à quel
point les idées met du temps à
remonter quelque part à investir
d'autres intellectuels à être portés
aussi dans le champ politique à investir
les médias et je pense que c'est aussi
ainsi qu'on y arrivera et l'autre point
je m'arrêterai là toute la difficulté
qu'on a aussi à définir un modèle
français c'est qu'en fait pendant un
moment on nous a fait honte de mondo de
modèles on nous a dit que ce modèle
n'était pas performant qu'on n'était pas
assez productif qu ont payé trop
d'impôts que nos fonctionnaires il y en
avait trop qu'ils étaient pas productif
non plus etc etc et finalement de ce qui
a fait nos forces et de ce qui fait nos
forces et on l'a vu d'ailleurs pendant
la crise on a pensé que c'était des
faiblesses on en a même eu honte même
chose pour les 35 heures par exemple qui
est une réforme que certains écologistes
côtés notamment anglo-saxons aux états
unis peuvent nous envier eh ben on en a
honte et c'est ça aussi la difficulté
pour nous je pense de définir un modèle
c'est que pendant trop longtemps on a eu
on nous a dit ça va pas du tout maintien
puisque vous parliez de la question des
fonctionnaires leur efficacité d'or et
de leur image pour poser coûté une
réaction intéressante elle est signée du
président de la république il était à
marseille vous souvenez il parle avec le
maire de la ville une sorte de donnant
donnant ok on donne de l'argent à
marseille mais il faudrait peut-être que
les fonctionnaires municipaux
travaillent différemment écouter en même
temps qu'on investit monsieur le maire
moi j'attends de vous que vous réformer
et je sais que vous en avez envie
et on aura aussi cette exigence de fizi
parce qu'on ne va pas se substituer un
système qui n'arrivent plus à se
financer parce que il a construit
une mécanique qui n'avance plus
par des petits arrangements par des
faiblesses mais la deuxième ville de
france ne peut pas supporter cette
situation je vous le dis en toute
franchise alors il parle des
fonctionnaires municipaux et évidemment
mais ça à sa rejoint une question qui
est quand même centrale de l'efficacité
de l'état un mot erwan le nord là dessus
je suis plutôt d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire le présent a pu boire sans
bien connaître le rôle la municipalité
de marseille mais effectivement la
question aujourd'hui essentielle est pas
tant la question du niveau de dépenses
publiques que de son efficacité on ne
met énormément d'argent dans l'éducation
jude et à l'heure je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse être satisfait des résultats de
nos écoles ça veut alors il ya eu de
très bons résultats on est bien meilleur
que de nombreux autres pays mais vous le
savez on est l'un des pays où il ya le
plus de reproduction sociale pour dire
rapidement de tout le cdc quand on voit
l'argent qu'on dit mais c'est pas normal
je pense pas qu'on puisse satisfaire de
ces de ces deux de ses résultats mais
est ce que ça vient des fonctionnaires
forcément mais ça vient pas ça vient pas
des fonctionnaires ça vient pas d'eux
d'une pelle dans une catégorie de
personnes en particulier ça construit et
là je suis assez d'accord excuse à
emmanuel macron ça vient d'un système
qui s'est construit de telle façon où on
n'a pas nécessairement optimiser la
dépense on how dans l'éducation par
exemple j'avais finalement peu de moyens
pour le terrain beaucoup pour les
administrations qui a des questions de
réparation de moyens c'est c'est comme
dans tout dans toute organisation en
fait quand même dans vos familles quand
des habitudes sont prises c'est pas de
la faute d'une personne en particulier
c'est la faute d'un système qui coûte
tout le monde a accepté et qu'il est
difficile à remettre en place manquant
neuf sur cette question de l'efficace
moi je prends moi je pense qu'il faut
qu'on sorte un peu de l'idéologie on a
une passion idéologique en france hier
d'un côté il ya ceux qui disent l'état
et qui sont un peu en vie privée et puis
de l'autre il ya ceux qui disent un peu
comme erwan le noir tout à l'heure là
encore on la joue et c'est moi je pense
qu'il faut être justement comme les
allemands comme les sud coréens et sud
coréens ils dépensent quatre et demi
pour cent de leur pic dans la
recherche/développement j'aimerais bien
qu'on en fasse autant en france et dans
ça y est les financements publics et des
financements privés j'aimerais bien
qu'on travaille en coalition le problème
de ce pays c'est la segmentation le cil
otage les acteurs ne savent pas
travailler ensemble pendant le vide j'ai
un ami qui était médecin chef dans un
service hospitalier est en charge de
l'unité commune et qui misait pour la
première fois on a organisé une
conférence téléphonique avec la médecine
de ville
je lis mais tu as tu l'as pas fait avant
enfin c'est parce que d'un côté et
praticiens hospitaliers plus de l'autre
les médecins de ville et ça c'est pareil
partout on ne sait pas travailler en
équipe en quelque sorte or l'éducation
la santé on voit bien que ce qui est
performant et ce qui marche dans la
santé c'est quand l'hôpital travaille
avec la ville avec le réseau de
pharmacies avec la veille
épidémiologique avec les patients il
faut arriver à construire comme ça une
culture d'équipé à l'échelle d'un
territoire et ça c'est un truc qui
manque cruellement et moi je pense que
l'état il peut jouer un rôle de
facilitation sûr ça qu'on l'attend et on
va on va terminer le dernier thème ce
sera le déclinisme on va écouter
évidemment celui qui porte ou qui a
préempté ce thème là dans l'instant vous
imaginez qu'ils mais j'aurais quand même
vous vous entendre or là luc pour
boucler cette partie la question de la
rapidité ou de la violence du changement
parce que si on parle de nouveaux
modèles et notamment de transition
écologique
est ce qu'elle peut être autrement que
violente cette transition écologique
pour être efficace en fait l'argent ce
qui met la réalité c'est que la
transition écologique c'est dur il faut
pas mentir et moi j'aurais aimé entendre
des politiques nous dire c'est pas
simple à gérer c'est pas simple à gérer
pourquoi parce qu'on ne prend pas des
gens comme les économistes j'aimais me
mets dedans le fond c'est à dire on
prend des gens qui travaillent dans
l'automobile et on dit ah bah tiens ils
vont aller dans l'agro écologie que ça
se passe pas comme ça en fait c'est pas
des flux faut faire la formation et à
des personnes c'est pas simple de
reformer tout simplement je ne sais pas
si nous on serait capable d'être formés
à d'autres métiers par exemple voilà
tout simplement ce n'est pas simple donc
c'est un vrai défi
la réalité c'est que plus on s'y prend
tôt plus ça se passera bien parce que on
aura le temps de pouvoir justement gérer
socialement cette transition en douceur
mais le problème c'est qu'il faut s'y
prendre le plus tôt possible pour que ça
puisse se faire parce qu'il va falloir
gérer la question de l'emploi et faire
en sorte surtout que personne ne tombent
dans la pauvreté alors le déclinisme
eric zemmour évidemment pour ne pas le
nommer on écoute c'était lors du débat
face à jean luc mélenchon sur bfm tv ça
faisait longtemps si on continue comme
cela
la france en 2050
sera un liban en grand
c'est à dire tout simplement un pays où
il y aura à peu près des communautés qui
comme l'a dit l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur collomb étaient
côte à côte et seront face à face
il y aura plus de pauvreté plus de
misère et surtout plus de désordre plus
de violence comme ce qui se passe
actuellement
alors on est certainement pas les
missions de foule tous les médias
français qui a le plus parlé de zemmour
depuis quinze jours rassurez vous mais
bon dans une dent dans une émission sur
le nouveau modèle français on peut
difficilement faire faire l'impasse
c'est est ce que votre rue c'est aussi
une réponse à ceux des joutes âgées
parce qu'il s'est pas passé une émission
depuis que j'ai sorti se trouve que nos
livres sont sortis de même jour il passe
pas forcément
mais mes bébés mais en fait moi je pense
que zemmour il ya une chose qu'il faut
arrêter c'est de se contenter d
indignation en sert de dire oh la la
c'est un fasciste un misogyne et c'est
parce que il a un discours qui séduit
énormément et on voit qu'il ya une
dynamique autour de lui qui est pas
niable et je pense qu'elle est liée à
cette angoisse du déclin elle est allée
à 7,1 alors le discours qu'il est qui et
qui est la réponse qui me propose et
totalement délirante c'est à dire que
c'est c'est une sorte de il reconstruit
une espèce de france imaginaire et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont tellement pris
aux tripes dans cette angoisse du déclin
que cette reconstruction d'une patrie
imaginaire et peut apparaître comme une
réponse je crois que la meilleure
réponse à ce discours et c'est en
réalité de traiter les causes et les
mots du déclin français en construisant
un projet un projet de société moi je
crois vraiment que cette absence de
modèle collectif qui nous projette dans
l'avenir explique profondément que des
personnages comme sa prospère dans le
débat public mais mais mais est-ce que
avec une société qui est de plus en plus
et gothique est de plus en plus
fracturées est-ce que c'est tout
simplement possible alors moi il ya un
contre argument à ce que je viens de
dire c'est effectivement notre capacité
de d'acceptation des règles avec la
crise covin donc oui j'ai je vous donne
le les deux à rions un peu
contradictoire oui bien sûr les règles
de la crise que vit depuis surtout elle
est gothique et fracturés dans le
discours médiatique mais quand vous
allez à saint-apollinaire où on a
construit un quartier intergénérationnel
quand vous allez à figeac où il ya des
réussites extraordinaire quand vous
allez à l'oncopôle de toulouse quand
vous allez à loos en gohelle quand vous
allez dans ces territoires où il se
passe des choses extraordinaires la
société l est pas et gothique est
fracturée et des biens français qui ont
fait pas mais le mouvement des gilles et
jo nous et pour moi c'est une manif anti
vaccins formidable un signe de cohésion
et gilet jaune c'était un désir de
cohésion le temps cercle il faut lire le
reportage de florence aubenas par
exemple les gilet jaune à marmande des
mamans solos qui n'avait presque plus
aucun contact social qui retrouve la
chaleur la possibilité de délibéré et à
cette envie de construire quelque chose
ensemble ça fait ça de sa joue sur des
affects qui sont ils pour une population
qui se sent exclue et qu'il veut
redevenir part du mois c'était
extrêmement positif et donc donc si vous
voulez je pense qu'il se passe des
choses extraordinaires mais il faut
qu'on les fasse le faut qu'on fasse
vibrer ces choses là c'est encore trop
localisé il ya trop de pièces du puzzle
éparpillés et puis surtout on n'est pas
en déclin enfin faut se rendre compte
qu'on est un petit pays moi je suis
toujours impressionné on est là 5e ou la
suisse sixième puissance économique
mondiale avait vu la taille de notre
pays nous et rien n'est pas beaucoup
enfin moi quand je vois ça et que je
vois que on a un siège à l'onu qu'on est
dans les négociations géopolitique etc
pardon mais de quel déclin de quel
déclin parle-t-on quand on regarde la
réalité de notre place dans le monde ce
n'est pas vrai nous ne sommes pas en
déclin est ce qu'on pourrait faire mieux
oui dans le domaine la transition
écologique et oui d'un point de vue de
justice sociale là je suis entièrement
d'accord il y avait une demande de
renouvellement du contrat social et ça
faut pas qu'on le loupe et un non en
fait on n'est pas en déclin par contre
il ya oui il ya des rapports de classes
au sein de notre pays ça c'est sûr il ya
des intérêts qui peuvent ne pas être
convergents c'est l'histoire de la
démocratie mais faut pas faux pas les
masques avec autre chose il ya une
formule de sylvain tesson ou cité je
voulais c'est la cité oui la france est
un paralysie peuple et des gens qui se
rendent en faire oui c'est pas seulement
un bon mot c'est pas seulement un bon
moi je suis pas totalement d'accord avec
ça mais ce que je sais que ce qui est
constitutif de notre identité c'est le
lien politique et si les français ont un
malheur collectif c'est parce qu'il voit
bien que notre démocratie notre système
politique fonctionne pas très bien ils
sont il ya beaucoup de précarité et
d'injustice mais ils sont quand on
regarde la moyenne européenne plutôt
satisfaits de leur situation personnelle
des français mais ce qu'ils expriment
c'est beaucoup de malheur collectif du
point de vue l'organisation je suis en
désaccord sur une chose avec ce crédit
aurore c'est sur le déclin il ya quand
même par exemple l'éducation l'industrie
villes moyennes et les petites villes
qui sont deux des clans objectif en
français le déclin éducatif ça ce n'est
pas un mythe le niveau scolaire s'est
effondré c'est de l'injustice plus que
du déclin je serais tenté de dire soit
on a une disparition de certains pans
industrielle par exemple mais ce sont
des choix politiques enfin je dirais le
déclin n'arrive pas comme ça de manière
magique et roanne ont le de la justice
puisque les déclarants mal étayée les
deux il ya une injustice profonde dans
le système éducatif par exemple il ya
effectivement aussi un élément de déclin
ya le chili le chiffre du pipe par tête
français qui a décroché par rapport à
nos zones man aux pays-bas homologue
depuis le début des années 80 assez
sensiblement donc il ya des éléments ça
veut pas dire que qui sont qui vous
indiquent des pistes pour que ça aille
mieux ça veut pas dire on est quand même
très très loin d'être dans l'état du
liban je crois qui est un pays qui
souffre énormément on est économique et
en 2050 voilà
défend on a de la marge mais mais le
discours de d'eric zemmour je pense que
là où ils raisonnent c'est que auprès de
gens vous le disais quand il ya une
demande sociale il ya 10 20 en publiant
ont publié des sortes et des livres sur
la peur du déclassement et le sentiment
de déclassement des classes moyennes je
crois effectivement mais comme vous
l'avez dit l'un et l'autre qu'il n'y a
pas eu de réponse politique à cette peur
du déclassement il n'y a pas eu d'autres
modèles il ya eu d'autres propos de
d'offres qui est politique qu'il est
occupé et donc effectivement si les
extrêmes et singulièrement et l extrême
droite aujourd'hui occupent largement
l'espace public c'est que
il n'y a pas de débat public ces qui a
pas d'offre alternative qui était
travaillée et comme vous parliez tout à
l'heure de travail et les idées ça fait
des années qu'ils travaillent le champ
des idées pour pour disséminer les leurs
sans avoir réellement 2 2
d'opposants en face qui proposent des
offres en gossip englobante il ya quand
même un jeu reprend la formule de
sylvain tesson la france et un paradis
peuplé de gens qui se croient en enfer c
on retrouve sa dent dans des études
d'opinion par exemple la dernière étude
qui a été faite par frick dhabi stewart
show pour pour l'ifop sur la jeunesse
ils en ont publié un livre on voit une
jeunesse aujourd'hui moi j'avais été
frappé par ceux ci 30% des jeunes
estiment que c'est une malchance de
vivre aujourd'hui aussi horla luxe qu'on
parle cette anxiété climatique qui est
très forte dans cette dans cette
génération
ça que ça peut être à la fois un frein
ou alors un moteur puissant c'est un
moteur puissant ça peut être un moteur
puissant en fait on doit être à la
hauteur des enjeux tout simplement est
ce qui est dommage dans tout ça c'est
que l'on parle de déclin alors qu'on a
tout pour pouvoir mettre en place cette
transition écologique et sociale en à la
banque centrale européenne qui peut être
un outil particulièrement efficace on a
des institutions au niveau français qui
sont relativement robuste je trouve même
s'il faut les réformes et on a une main
d'oeuvre qui est bien formé on a des
services publics qui reste quand même de
bonne qualité même chose sur la question
des infrastructures et en inde et on a
quand même l'une des mains d'oeuvre les
plus productifs du monde donc
globalement on pourrait on peut y
arriver en fait on peut y arriver mais
par contre je suis entièrement d'accord
avec vous il faut proposer de bonnes
idées c'est pour ça que j'ai font un
green new deal qui est un plan
d'investissements massifs dans la
transition écologique et ça ça permet de
créer des emplois de résoudre les
questions sociales en partie et puis de
remettre la france sur la voie d'une
prospérité
carbonique tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat on a eu un petit souci technique
peut-être on va rendre l'antenne de
toute façon se leurrent 19h28 c'est
notre heure habituelle le nouveau modèle
français sécher alary édition merci
encore une fois à tous d'avoir participé
à ce sens public